- Well, there's a recall
election for governor coming here
and a friend of yours,
Caitlyn Jenner is running.
So does that make it easier or harder
to decide who to support?
Because I know in all seriousness
it's a completely different
job than when you were acting
and it's a big undertaking you know?
And it's a lot of work.
So is it hard for you when it's a friend
or is it easier for you to be like,
"No, I'm gonna cut the crap,
I'm gonna tell you this."
Like is it easy or hard for you?
- Well, it's not easy or hard.
It makes no difference
to me because the fact
of the matter is, is that
I stay out of the race.
As I've said many times.
I said that Gavin Newsome
is a friend of mine.
Caitlin is a friend of mine, a lot
of other people that may
run and will announce
are friends of mine but
I don't get involved
because, you know I have the
USC Schwarzenegger Institute,
which is a bipartisan institute,
kinda like a think tank in a way.
We talk about various important issues
of healthcare, infrastructure,
environmental issues
homeless issues, and so on and so forth.
So the only way you really
can do that successfully
is if you're able to bring
Democrats and Republicans
to the experts in the various
different subjects together.
And so therefore I don't
want to get involved
in a political arena at all.
I don't to support Democrats
or to support Republicans.
But I said, I stay out of it.
- I think that's really
important, that think tank.
That's a really important, I mean,
on a global level, I
think that's important
that no matter what our beliefs are,
no matter what your principles,
that the core thing is that everyone wants
to be happy and healthy.
You wanna be able to get your kids healthy
and get, you know,
healthcare and, and all that.
So I think that that think tank idea is,
that's what really needs
to happen regardless
of what political side
of the fence you land on.